hey guys I want to take a moment and
encourage all of you to nominate someone
for the Australian of the Year awards in
2021 I was at the awards in Canberra
earlier this year as part of their 60th
anniversary celebrations and it struck
me that you know there's such a diverse
collection of people who are recognized
in the Australian of the Year awards
incredible stories wonderful
achievements but we don't get to
celebrate and all of them in these
awards if no one nominates them so I
want to encourage you to nominate
someone yourself by telling you about
the woman that I'm nominating for next
year's awards her name is Sarah gray
she's the founder and president of an
organization called oz EE their charity
that exists who support individuals and
families who are affected by ears and
offal ik gastrointestinal diseases now
you've probably never heard of those
before a bit of a mouth for the name
even and that's because these are quite
rare conditions I only know about them
because my son is one of the people who
has one of them now
when we were first when my son was first
diagnosed with this we knew so little
about it even doctors we talked to you
we're like what is that and so to find
out information about how do we manage
this disease and sort of connected
people and see if there was anyone else
you understood the struggles we were
going with we're going through I should
say we really relied on the work of ize
to be able to help us understand what
exactly we were walking into
and so the work of Sarah is incredibly
valuable to us as a family
even though most people are never gonna
find out who she is or what she does I
want to honor the work that she's done
sort of thank her for the incredible
contribution she's made to my family and
I and also help all Australians know
that these are the kinds of people who
make up our society and that's how our
communities function through the work of
people like these who often aren't
recognized so you may know someone who
does things that no one knows about that
really help you support the community
that you live in their work deserves to
be honored and their stories deserve to
be told
it only takes a single nomination for
someone to become an Australian of the
Year so please consider it think about
it and head to the website it's
Australian of the Year org dot a you
have a good one guys